foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the reason it's like that is because I
just got back from the gym I have a
whole lot of time to do anything yeah
his elbows are sore on the rail though
like I have a bad shoulder and it's been
making it work now oh you're showing oh
you got to take that joint support that
I use with uh Advanced GG uh you know
get the gummy yo they got no audio still
hard like no audio no audio no now they
say perfect okay yeah it's perfect now
yo girl so what you do is take the
advanced GG
um joint support take it yeah you gotta
get your joint support bro
real real quickly sir get them gummies
bro yeah
he's been debunked oh the liver King
yeah
liver pills oh you eating liver pills
yeah yeah
that's you TJ huh yeah
all right
the effects of liver pills
yeah don't be hating on everything in
this stream my dude
you see the Xbox
the whole Comics actually let me know
not to bring you back oh yeah yeah
he's bringing the room down yeah yeah I
was not here though hey hey hold on all
these different perspectives that's what
I tried to tell them everybody
that's right okay they're used to kids
oh
oh for the time what's going on Elder
Scrolls Online yeah
oh yeah
well I don't say no hosts nobody
don't don't say anything yet all right
they walk into the ring people go you're
gonna have like major announcements in
the show up any second what could be
inside Xbox 2.0 what a dope
I hope they do the format better man a
lot of people didn't like it 2010 in the
building
rubber for turn 10 today
[Music]
look at throw your tent up throw your 10
up
turned Taylor to build him you know what
it is when those dudes won today when
they come outside oh hold on I gotta
switch to my Xbox glasses oh God we
outside nah buddy we gonna see all of
this in the chat question for the chat
do you guys like the format we have now
because I'm gonna eventually have an
overlay made for us
I said we like the boxes it's cool
I said your attic oh
game words they're gonna be in yeah
[Music]
set in a lush Dynamic World it
introduces epic storytelling and you can
form alliances with new and familiar
Minecraft Mobs to stop the invading
pigments
Minecraft Legends will let you play the
story dreams and so far as an online I
was right experienced Minecraft first
yep and it will also feature wonder if
it's an order of release yep the four
players each Works to destroy their
opponents some space
the game will support us
online matchmaking what's up this
actually looks interesting they say four
player uh experience PVP do they say
that it looks like a cross-platform and
it's been wonderful
Dude on the Minecraft Universe because
you know their battery life is dead so
after they battery went out we get to
beat them up oh the super chat's coming
in
that goal strategy games yes
we'll take care of it we're super
excited to share more details about PVP
games or between the the games thanks
for 138 two thousand Super Chat turn ten
ride or die throw your turn tens up
there are some really cool features that
make PVP unique Killian brown with the
two dollar Super Chat what's the blunts
lit let's go individual players aren't
able to win on their own they must
cooperate successful
with the five dollars
do they make their own smile you're off
collecting
we already we have our favorite roles
but we changed them up
is procedurally generated just like it
is in campaign this means that each PVP
session is different than the last we'll
go for a lot different every time
the valleys are the mountains are where
the secrets are I think those are so far
where the towers are I turned it up guys
in Minecraft Legends the piglens are an
ever-present threat and this includes
PVP the piglens are on their own side
they're trying to kill both of you at
the same time so the opposing team is
not the only thing you need to worry
about the one with Ray Tracer
Russia today it's a possibility in PvP
there's something for everyone
for players who like action they can go
attack the piglens or lay Siege to the
enemy base for players who enjoy
exploration it doesn't search the world
to find resources for their team
or Scout the enemy base I'm just saying
Gathering resources to help the team out
that's super important but whenever I
get into a PVP match the first thing I
try to do is to track down the Regal
tiger it's my favorite mob to ride
because it's really fast on the low I
can see this pop at all like building
you can spend your time building
defenses
and you need to be ready
I like those yeah I think a lot of kids
so the first thing I do when I'm outside
see where the enemy base is first thing
I build is what we call an upgrade Tower
Place that in the back away from the
enemy
so I really pride myself
is this a survival Minecraft
yeah
really important
you have to start with a lot of times
after that you can just add whatever you
want freestyle a little bit
I like to add different layers so my
points have to find their way through to
my base almost like a maze and then once
things actually hide my ice traps behind
them to catch enemies off guard when it
comes time to finally I think strategy
is to make a forward just outside the
enemy base then I get the biggest
strongest mobs I can as fast as I can
and start sending them in I don't know
about that then I can smash Down the
Walls and claim victory
the real fun of PVP is creating a
strategy having a game plan deciding how
you think you're going to crush the
enemy and then all of a sudden the hosts
tell you yeah
I can't do my attack now I've got to
like build an anti-seage Tower which
isn't it this is crazy stop the Redstone
sometimes you like I have no idea what
they're doing RTS do and then you
shouldn't you certainly find out very
quickly resources we need help we need
to help Microsoft play the devs a while
back we have somebody on our Dev team
uses strategies
yeah
that's why we still love playing it
every day
[Music]
I can see this game if it's done right I
guess
as big as Minecraft if it's done right
foreign
games do really well on PC
but release date yes I do like the uh
style of this show so far April 18th
yes I agree Jesus April oh January
people thought maybe February
all right let's go first the dominoes
are falling April they're giving dates
baby all right who's up
the team is hard at work the next
generation of Forza Motorsports built
from the ground up to take advantage of
the Xbox series consoles this is the
most technically Advanced racing game
ever made today
I'm joined by some of our amazing that
was low-key like what's up
sound real and feel real yeah we just
don't put it in the class before it's a
motorsport
yo yo
so just the good old boys
I ain't go live man this pacing's lit I
like this formula it's five Forza
Motorsport features
this includes over 100 new to Motorsport
cars the most modern race cars we've
ever featured on our roster racing is
violent it's a bad race track the
advanced on the car physics model for
greater than Forza Motorsport five six
and seven combined this makes our
Driving Experience more fun and
rewarding in the way the car accelerates
nice our materials
at higher resolutions and optimized for
a Cutting Edge Ray tracing experience
music our paints are sourced using a
spectrophotometer to capture multiple
data
this yields a paint model that has a
much more realistic light responses
and directionality look at the speed up
dirt accumulation it's more realistic
accumulations
these Innovations tell the story of the
world where you put into a race and
reflects the marks and Battle Scars
you see the grass or the side with the
puppies this is our best sounding
Fortune Motorsport ever and the first to
be mixed natively for immersive audio
formats like Windows
[Music]
system has been rebuilt from the ground
up to deliver a new level of Sonic depth
and authenticity for our players
and turbo change the car sounds in
fortnite
our regional track announcer system an
improved Tire and Suspension audio
bringing you know the game pure for
tomorrow sport like never before
every engine
oh
I'm approved
Forza Motorsport launches with 20
environments built from the ground up
for this generation yes you'll get to
race on iconic fan favorites as well as
five all new to Motorsport locations
including our first in South Africa
kyalami
we capture our environments to an
incredible level of detail when we
reference a track our team comes back
with over three terabytes of highly
detailed photogrammetry and Laser scan
data through the power of the Xbox
series consoles we're able to use this
data to draw up to 10 times more detail
than previous generations
dense grass and overgrowth that was
crazy
he showed a fully procedural cloud
system that evolves organically tracks
consisting of tens of thousands of fully
animated movie Spectators
ensures a constantly evolving racing
meanwhile Dynamic track temperatures wet
driving surfaces and rubbering in ensure
that no two laps ever play the same man
this game looks amazing I love the
detail our talented team of artists have
built into kailan a lot of people going
to buy Xbox
and the Vista is truly breathtaking oh
night time you can see the distant light
blows of the city yeah the beautiful
visual touch
logo itself creates visual impact every
time you see it thanks to Ray Trace Club
elimination
hundreds of thousands of light rays
accumulate colors
we're rendering all our environments 60
FPS
all smooth mirror and flat glasses
and authenticity
environments
you can experience all of this you know
our incredible new online racing mode
car building focused
it was their only low we visited we
cannot wait a single player get your
hands on this incredible game
February 17th come on
did you see it on the helmet yeah that
doesn't look crazy
February 17th
coming 2023 yeah
I'm so mad because I'm supposed to have
a date that's not good man that's not
good
tomorrow
that's me and you're probably wondering
how I ended radio
check this out
it's powering up my new robot arm the
redacted games everything sync up with a
beat oh
that's right hold it for the Jet Set
Radio okay I like this art style
yep
what in the hell am I looking at no the
names
one boss at a time
a little bit of classic
um
it's the people that make Evil Within
yeah sit right there
okay ready for more naturally
look like they're making it future
Rockstar
I should be the legendary
gaming walks thank you for all your
support over the years and I'm John
Johannes director on hi-fi
[Applause]
oh yo you know what it reminds me of
what was that game
spent all that money on the kids
the joy that we have first
um Sunset overdraft yeah that's what I
said literally so good so everyone
thinks
they're spooky games
but this is clearly something totally
different and if this game hasn't
already leaked fingers crossed we hope
it's a pleasant surprise
let's have some fun November 29th with
the format crazy
[Music]
during combat but everything you do
synts up like an awesome music video
that's HiFi Rush Oh this looks still
bound the better place
you can see the beat moves the world
around
your attacks will automatically sink to
land on the beach
like this
Landing beat hits on the Chicago finish
that adds unique music
will relax
[Applause]
[Music]
just won the direct for her I'm good for
the rest of the show okay
the key here is feeling real clean bro
yep very colorful very Nintendo is yes
it comes out on Valentine's Day
see right there cut scenes oh that's
cool danger
you name it this is good this is a good
way to demonstrate that ongoing jam
session of a game can we admit that
pacing is phenomenal
it's like a companion literally a direct
2.0 it helps you yeah it's a better
version right now
well we did that later let's just get
this let's just finish it
first that's why I can't stand Xbox
heads
man's friends
[Music]
possibility
Hi-Fi rough is PaRappa the Rapper
I use the light decors
now okay I'm feeling the vibe taking
down the bosses
asking for but good you'll fight through
each department to take them all on each
level with their own musical spin on the
Rock shot yo and then we have a show
shout out to the OverWatch screen
[Music]
the whole game
nine inch nail Black Keys prodigy
and we think it's like nothing you've
ever played before either
this feels real 90 metacritics
[Applause]
um you guys there's a surprise I'm not
gonna foil about this game Joy
pretty rock star move chai pop my Rush
stealing the show right now
still in the show but I was doing way
more
and it's out right now on your Xbox
let's go Prophet Kings so not only were
you super psyched for you to play this
we're happy to tell you that you can
play
drop down
yo how many years have we been saying
they need to drop a game like it's right
now like
oh surprise somebody been listening mind
if I join all right I need the windows
the windows game packs are fresh every
day I'm gonna tell you right now we need
to give Phil a legend of the year every
year
those guys don't play games well Twitter
is a game it's crazy they revealed a
game and released it in the same breath
that's the but when I talk about this
surprise the one that's what I like
that's what happens when you have a Game
Pass Studios yay get it today January
25th boy you could shop
okay
and they have their own event as well
straight we're going straight for it we
do it straight we're going straight
I think we need to jump into that one as
soon as this stream is over shout out to
ladies say with the twenty dollars
saying twenty dollars for them tonight
cinematic teaser for The Elder Scrolls
online's next chapter I'm pleased to
reveal ESO
necronology
class called The Arcanist it's only our
third new class since launch and we know
you're gonna love it the arcanus wields
magic warlock energy this is I'm in
trouble unique abilities never before
seen in this world so you can bring
Deadpool of course the experience of
exploring a new area of Tamriel was the
heart of every ESO chapter necron will
unfortunately
not seen in an Elder Scrolls game since
1994 where you will meet new characters
and enemies reunite with some old
friends and explore a story based around
the return of a well-known Daedric
prince just might remember from the
Dragonborn Skyrim DLC oh
but you don't have to wait for the
necron chapter to jump in we've got so
many amazing experiences
it's ridiculous if you love games like
Skyrim and Oblivion you'll feel right at
home amongst the thousands of stories
unfolding across every region in ESO
and as anyone who's played a classic
Elder Scrolls game knows all about those
feelings when you're fully immersed in
the world
first encountered a dragon
you've got an entire province
or questioned if you were capable of
taking down a frost troll in Skyrim try
it for yourself and ESO what about the
moment you visited a city in Morrowind
that was built inside the shell of a
giant crab
for the Oblivion fans out there another
chance try the Colossal Daedric prince
hmm that's right any single player Elder
Scrolls because they raid I have a blast
simply by following the main quest line
or seek out lore and learn more about it
so that I need a buff you come across
go fishing
decorate and furnish your home you'll
not get a chance to customize your
character attack play it like an action
RPG
and when you're ready you can easily
engage in one of the best open world PVP
systems run dungeons co-op with your
friends for great loot foreign
we invite everyone who has not yet
experienced ESO to give it a try and
create your own stories in our shared
world there's no required subscription
and thousands of hours of content to dig
into
or with friends
explore nearly every corner of Tamriel
with no level restrictions it's magical
being able to travel almost
in addition to previous and current gen
Concepts including a purposeful next
year
an added bonus for Xbox players it's on
game pass
and starting today for a limited time
we're making all 20 DLCs free off the
rip any place
they try to get people to play Skyrim
they like DLCs
[Music]
don't show us in depth show us the
announcement and then say yo after the
show we can do more like yo go get that
did it say June yes
oh Arcane okay here we go here we go
foreign
something evil is swallowing up this
place bit by bit
okay
[Music]
they literally said it's not back for
butter left a day no I know I was joking
yeah
slide up on your shotgun blasting them
is out here we go welcome to redfall
Massachusetts where the calm seas and
sunny skies have been eclipsed by a
legion of vampires
redfall is a story driven shooter at its
heart which can be played single player
or co-op with up to four players
choose your hero each with their own
unique abilities and form the perfect
vampire slaying Squad to take back red
Falls haunted streets
at Arcane we make games where the world
itself is as important as the characters
redfall we take an exciting step forward
they're building a lovingly detailed
open world to deliver our largest
setting ever
every inch of our own model just
carefully handcrafted packed with
environmental stories
explore the streets of a quaint Island
Town
to the haunted forest to the decimated
seaside boardwalk and gorgeously
detailed landmarks energy
but it's not all danger all the time
there are safe places on the island
where you can rest up chat with
survivors
here we're at the fire station one of
your home bases
this is one place
there's something I need you to do which
is the Old Lighthouse in the bay it's
been used for over a century to keep
boats away from the coastline if we turn
it back on it's warning to anyone trying
to come to redfall right now easy right
now sway well the Lighthouse Keeper is a
real [__] joined up with those
cultists and took the damn lamp with
them oh she looking dope
here's a vampire known as the Shroud
shrouds blanket the area in darkness
disorienting their prey
they hurl lethal projectiles and can
even shift through the floor to avoid
damage
you can go play on a heart
I'm playing on touchy feeling Boss look
at the house
oh no nope that's when I go right
outside dope
grandfather clock
vacuum is coming through
first
shooting with the steak shooting with
the steak oh
that's some bullet spongy uh vampire
right there
[Applause]
the lighthouse's back up but there's
more waiting for you taking down
vampires angers the vampire God who will
summon the Rook to take you down
let's transition to what you'll find
outside of the main story missions
there's so much waiting for you redfall
is filled with encounters that can pop
up anywhere like this Brewery that's
Fallen under cultist control save the
locals from being awesome to vampires
like our past games you can approach a
mission in many different ways oh that's
that Arcane saw was right
a tad approaching from different things
always be ready to improvise
Remy uses her combat robot free balls
I would say you know we'll try out what
was that other game that we just put out
uh death Loop none control knife
it's just that blood on the walls why
they gotta string you out put your blood
down the wall spell write verses on your
blood I said I gotta coat this bag
[Music]
yeah just all the options you can how to
tackle different missions
on his back wow wow
everyone's safe let's move on
he's like you that Herbie wants to have
me something exploring red ball will
take you beyond the boundaries as you
investigate
spaces to unravel the vampire secrets
these deadly layers change each time you
step inside
Jacob sends out his Raven to tag the
enemies below Dev follows up with his
teleporter instantly closing the gap
I like the combo move yeah the unique
synergies yeah
to destroy a nest you have to take right
get all of the vampires willing to die
horrible way to die
yeah
I can say it is though
um if anybody want to say that it was
like a leopard gecko now Escape The Nest
before it comes crashing down
because this is really story based yeah
it's just a lot more immersive it's not
just get to the seafood
spaces
all over the island yeah this is what we
ask for right look at the world
carefully
[Applause]
truly be safe until the vampires are
wiped from the map outside the main
story another one of your missions is to
take back red fall neighborhood by
neighborhood
find safe houses hidden all over the
island and then work your way up to the
vampire controlling the neighborhood
to reclaim this neighborhood you'll have
to defeat a powerful vampire called the
siphon
whether you die this Solo or with
friends each hero can take on any
situation
powerful unique abilities to the fight
and the upgrades you choose
ability can be upgraded to launch
teammates for Airborne attacks upgrade
Layla's umbrella ability with bullet
hail to absorb enemy bullets and release
the energy back at me
anyway customize your hero's ability
tree to match your playstyle I'm sure
they turned the difficulty down to show
off the game yeah
[Music]
well I'm gonna play on this mode anyways
foreign
[Music]
with their own unique abilities
foreign
thank you for visiting redfall thank you
for all the support you've shown Arcane
throughout the years we sometimes joke
that our games can be tough to define
the one thing that's consistent we make
the kinds of games we love to play and
that's how redfall was born we Blended
everything we love here at Arcane
immersive open worlds unique and
customizable heroes RPG and FPS games
and of course our signature storytelling
classic monsters of all time vampires
releasing today it's been amazing to see
how all of us have pulled together to
deliver our vision for something more
redfall is the biggest most ambitious
game we have ever made our teams Dove
head first into this new opportunity and
we can't wait for you to experience
redfall for yourself thankfully you
won't have to wait too much longer red
balls
and Forza is
2023.
well I'm gonna tell you this if that's
foreign
a couple people in the chat was like uh
Maddie you must lost his mind this this
game actually looks good with Cog will
win with Maddie's not liking the way
yeah he's not like he because he he
don't like the new Direction They on
oh okay got you half I'll take this
again
like all the newer arcade games are
getting more popular and he likes with
occasions
he likes when it was unpopulated himself
[Music]
okay so we got it so we actually did get
one more surprise
definitely did that yeah and the fact
that it launched today yeah
so that's the energy that attic wanted
when he said that he weren't you know
but wait there's more
so
I like high five rush I'm not gonna lie
let's go
gonna be in there today and be honest
with you look the most polished
and they said that uh for the limited
time only you get the 20 DLCs
could you imagine if ESO was your joint
and then like all the DLC first of all
could you imagine if you brought it over
I wonder if they made that I wonder if
they made the coming the G in coming at
six for a reason because it looks like a
six instead of a g
foreign
yeah you're right it is a six
so baby it is June yeah look why would
they put the six like that they they do
it yeah possibly and they just don't
have a day for it yeah they still have a
day for you right it could be right
they're probably trying to see what's
going to go on with the xenomac I mean
with this ABK deal so they don't know
the whole Elder Scrolls right down so I
don't know all right now I'm not doing
that all right you don't wanna you don't
want to see all those new all those DLCs
they give you for free King yeah no well
you know basically I mean to be honest
with you for a fan
and if you weren't able to afford all
those DLCs that's what's up that's
what's up
a smorgasbord you're gonna be busy yeah
that's that's basically it I mean be
honest with you
what we wanted them to do they did
everything that we asked them to do you
know the only probably thing that you
can walk away from this is uh where's uh
forces date that's it but everything
else was they gave you dates
they gave you more than you asked for
because they only told you it was gonna
be three games there and they actually
gave you that um plus one fail
and released today so they've revealed
and released today
I mean
can't disagree with that
out of 10 10 out of 10 for me 10 out of
10. 10 out of ten out of ten perfect
show 10 out of nine for what they said
all right so we all knew going in but
yeah
that you was expecting that Forza thing
so how is it perfect if if they didn't
give you something that used well the
Forza Forza look like how I wanted it to
look if I'm going to be disappointed
with the ambiguity ambiguity with the
date
it's still it they still haven't
disappointed me with past June
they can catch them they can catch the
heat yeah you said you need dates
AJ said he needed Hard dates yes I
wanted to see everything at the show
they're gonna give you around about
rightful yes definitely lock that down
um Minecraft look they showed me more
that they made me more interested in
Minecraft yeah facts right so I thought
Minecraft was going to be a dub I walked
in say okay yo this is an eight right
eight eight seven Minecraft kind of
bumped it up once I saw the Bengal tiger
and I got a Bengal tiger Quest I'm like
okay I'll probably play for a little bit
like you know we played with Tim Dogg
with the other joint
um so I probably play it probably 10
times and then if it's really fun we're
probably stream it a whole lot more
right okay so that's a game that I
wasn't looking for that I didn't care
about and I and I had gave it automatic
loss then the the high five Rush
that was good I I thought they was going
to say something like it'll come out in
February or they come out in in March or
something like that now and them dudes
is like today
and I did not expect them and then you
know the eso again I was trying to stay
away from it but then they gave you well
every DLC that you did Miss if you was
playing it or you didn't get inside this
game here's every DLC I I can't I've
always said they tried to make uh uh
fake hosts they they have a bad Pace to
be the shows this is exactly the the
format and the pacing was 10 out of ten
yeah so for me it's 10 out of 10. it's
just I know be perfect
thing so then you're gonna hold it back
from a date give it a nine I give it a
nine no but yeah it can't drop no
further than the nine
nothing
let's get to it Michael where you at
developer direct
I thought the cartel was great this it
was the best produced Xbox show I've
seen in a while actual people don't want
to see uh like Executives they want to
see the people who actually made the
games these people are passionate and uh
it was a bit unfortunate that as Forza
went a bit stacked but it's getting its
own show so I'm sure they want to
celebrate the release date with their
fans was getting its own yeah so it's
coming I think it's tomorrow actually
yeah
um the one thing Hi-Fi Rush great
stealth drop I loved it but you have to
be careful Microsoft because now they've
sent a precedent well everybody
I don't know but like people when they
watch these shows you know they can't
blue blossoms anymore they gotta take it
easy we gotta be like all right let's
watch the show and maybe don't get don't
don't throw in too many surprises but
they they did a fantastic job as well
and check out our coverage on Lords of
gaming guys getting down there right now
we'll go get that go get that up right
did you press the button on your stream
deck I was I thought I was in control
don't worry about that don't worry about
what I thought I did I just want to ask
uh the Cali family you know my brother
bone it was only one day
Forza
they gave you uh uh Whatchamacallit
redfall they gave you Minecraft
I was in an l
uh oh he said L he like oh no he said
yeah he said it's a slight l in his
opinion okay you know bone let's go talk
about it baby tomorrow it's coming
tomorrow man don't worry about it don't
worry about it where you at 24 hours
yeah
um I was thinking the same thing about
Forza until he just mentioned that I
said oh yeah they do got their own thing
that's coming up so I'll I'll I won't
hold that against them maybe tomorrow it
might be a tweet or something if they
don't but um I highly doubt it yeah very
surprised yeah I I think it was it's by
far one of the best shows they put on
presentation wise they got all of the
they got all of the execs out of the
room it's like all right this is y'all
show we're gonna talk about what you
guys are doing and I think that's what
people really want to see so it was a
really good start to 2023 for them
um the fact that they did have a
surprise that was the biggest day for me
I kept telling people I was like listen
I don't care what it is they just need
to give us something else something else
in order to like not make up for last
year and the situation that we went
through as Xbox Gamers but just to say
we hear you and this is something that
we're gonna do extra to try to you know
you know at least start the year off
right so I I that really did take it up
like another point for me because I was
like King I came in like this is
probably going to be at least an eight
because they did set proper expectations
for it yes
seeing that seeing Forza just and people
love Horizon but Motorsport has always
been home for me I've always loved it I
love Motorsport man because it's all
about track racing and track racing is
all about precision and it's great and
um I I truly truly am impressed by that
so I can't wait to see what they do with
that but redfall just like I said
outside of the stuff we heard on the
outside when it comes to the co-op
aspect with not having you have to play
with people to do this and that to get
your uh progression to go forward that's
fine and all I hate it but I like
completely solo though you can but but
if you're playing with other people you
uh is based on the host that you're
playing with so yeah
so with with that being the only
downside too I really like what they're
doing it looks clean the Gunplay looks
really good and you know how we are
about Gunplay cops yeah yeah Gunplay got
to be on point and it looks like that it
actually is that especially with the
weight and stuff that you can not really
feel but you can see just seeing it on
the screen and stuff you bought this in
the chat last word what but
um yeah man I'm really excited I I'm
definitely jumping into
um I'm jumping into Hi-Fi rush today
um I I definitely that really got me
interested it reminded me of like Brutal
Legends and stuff like that with music
and everything and I was like definitely
gonna jump in on that so um yeah it was
good and I definitely give this show a 9
out of 10. I can't get them to 10
because they didn't give us the date for
Forza that might come tomorrow but if
everything was the way it needed to be
with a bit of 10 but at least a nine
today yeah no absolutely I hear where
you going what's going on Jansen that
was the best show I've ever seen from a
direct period beats Nintendo's it beats
Sony's state of play I don't really care
what anyone says it was good pacing no
one was over overly detailed gameplay
was good
um I give it nine nine out of ten
straight up I'm only disappointed before
not having a release okay what was your
standout
ha honestly Forza that game looks dang
near real life it looks crazy yeah it
looks phenomenal it's crazy I I am
disappointed in no release date I mean
if you watch the trailer the game looks
done I really am perplexed on why
there's no release date
it looks done
yeah we got to see what's going on
cooking behind the scenes addict where
you at with this developer director sir
uh I'll do two sir I'll give this format
of 10 out of 10 like the way that they I
don't care who says anything Xbox don't
switch from this yes please by far the
best format you've ever done but as far
as like the content it's like a eight
eight out of ten yeah you know I I don't
mind anything that was shown but you
know I I'm kind of mid on redfall
because you know I'm gonna give it a try
but it's not something like I'm excited
excited about I think that high uh High
Rush definitely the the star of the show
and you know I think they knew it was
gonna be the star of the show because of
how long they spent on it yeah they gave
it they gave it they felt like Minecraft
Legends was was good yeah I felt like
the you know June release date on uh the
Elder Scrolls was good if they would
have gave that Forza I would have gave
it a nine out of ten I feel like just
not giving that release date on Forza
I highly doubt we see a release date
tomorrow most likely that is past June
yeah can I add one more thing yes please
it is insane that they just released
ghostwire Tokyo and they already have a
new game coming out like right now yeah
that's quick turnaround and if you
noticed when he was talking he said this
the other dudes game like the the main
person of the studio that's not his game
yeah I'm in the same pocket as attic I
think let's just get off the rip the the
show format was the best they've ever
done period like 10 out of 10 developers
getting the shine no fluff no
foolishness no hey guys you know I don't
like that hey guys we're here stuff get
out of here so yeah that that was the
key just get right to it Forza showed
out definitely a showcase yes I was a
little disappointed that they didn't
have the date but um coming to obviously
2023 we'll see if it's June like if that
hits or whatever I did feel they needed
to nail that that wasn't really my main
to marry I just selfishly I'm gonna pull
an addict most these games are not hog
type games but the way they were shown
were excellent Hi-Fi Rush stole the show
Hi-Fi restaurant I was like Brutal
Legends Sunset Overdrive and then for me
it gave me the rhythm part where you
doing stuff to the B and the thing and
then doing like it just look for down
then when they had add the extra little
Co-op aspects with you know he's a team
that joke was fire like that you know
you know what it showed me the most they
finally got an outlet to show games that
works if they keep this format I'm not
looking at this from this car yeah
because a lot of this don't mean a whole
lot to me but when they start dropping
Horizon uh when they start dropping
fable about perfect Dart and they're
shown at these type of events okay
low-key and I forgot who said it earlier
the show format was so good like it if
they could maintain this format like how
this was for every joint moving forward
they will have the best direct format
out of everybody yeah I think that
format was amazing
and it was boom boom boom boom no
foolishness no marketing craziness no it
was it was all I was really impressed
with that so yeah and then and they gave
they played the game things they it was
really detailed they give you a lot of
red for we learned a lot I learned I
don't even care about Minecraft whatever
but I was like yo wow I've learned they
got a PVP they got this cross play they
showing it the gameplay it's not the the
guy on the screen all day the game is
they're talking while the game is going
on that's what they've always been
terrible at and now I'm like this is
what I'm talking about but yeah this is
this is phenomenal they did that eight
out of ten for me because just selfishly
the card games for Cog is more you know
the red Falls the star fields and all
that but no they they did that they did
that I got it I gotta check my cat I
think also if I may um yeah please this
is gonna say like a new president as
well because now Game Pass is part of
the main platform now so they got to
keep feeding it and how do you feed it
with all of these events yeah you got to
keep people subscribed all the time so
expect a lot more of these events and
that's that's gonna be the beast from
now on this is gonna be the no new new
one for Xbox one for that this has to be
the new one and I Gotta Give Elder
Scrolls showed out to me a lot like and
then what they offer they like the entry
point like yo if you don't play you've
never played We're not gonna say we're
giving you all 20 DLCs it keep jumping
in right now and we got the upgrade nah
it was it was fire it was I can't like I
said just that these particular games
are not the Cog strongest games for Cog
outside of red four baby fours I check
out but nah that was it I'm sorry I get
at it you know what the funny part is
about this like
this is just
tell June like yeah this is the first
half they got games they got games in
the in the later end of the year because
we didn't know nothing about the um high
five rush we
didn't know anything about this yeah so
you know all right that's the crazy part
all the fake insiders all the NBA dudes
nobody had this one on their radar a
game this polished a game that's
finished so there goes uh a lot of
credence to that crap that be in the
background I've seen the white papers
shut up
um nobody's seen the white papers on
this right but but the wildest thing is
you know boy was like nah you can say
today
because he got something talk yeah
because they got another and see that's
what I like I think we're gonna get to
that point of multiple shows finally
remember we used to get mad at them
everything is just E3 yeah and that we
get in the forza show they they still
technically doing the Elder Scrolls show
that we're not watching right now you
know what I'm saying like they keeping
this up because when you get to that
point when you have all the studios you
can't just Jam pack that into one show
and then say that's it for the year guy
and we're just gonna be quiet and nobody
knows what the hell you're doing my
biggest question yeah what's up
and I know this is going to be a point
of contention let's go oh let's go do
you think they were smart not to give
Jeff that money
Peaks and to to to show their stuff all
right and I'm only gonna say this right
let's go
attic has been very animate and yes your
own platform you need to show your stuff
at your own place
right
and Phil went there nothing to show
um
see you in January
and this is their own platform and they
nailed how to show I do but I do believe
xenomax Bethesda is in control of the
presentations now on how they're going
to run it because this marketing this
one here is the best one yeah so do you
think it was smart for them to skip the
game awards just to start establishing
their own ice fan base to be determined
I still think that they were in the
right for doing what they did but they
could have done some like seed thieves
or something we get a star field
showcase like next month just
everybody's acting like they don't got
anything else for us the year
no but he's asking about at the time
when everybody was pissed off because
watching the game awards and he was like
yo where the hell is actually
there was no promo for no games there
was no like is this game would have
shown well there right but the fact that
you're able to show it here and then
also drop it you can't do that on Jeff
joint
you cannot get it it's it's a it's a
good argument for it you know what I'm
saying I mean I get it it's just that
the problem is that maybe you have to
set the expectation that you're going to
do your own thing yeah and that we're
going to have minimal Presence at your
game
that before the video game right so the
same way they tweeted yo this is what we
showing it's gonna be 43 minutes it
would have hurt less and it just again
the fact that they had to yeah they had
a 22. but I understand what you said
because the end result ends up being
better for Xbox long term if they do
this if this is how the new This Is The
New Normal right we're getting these
can't whether it be quarterly or
whatever then the new normal is better
then then we like I said Gamers will
always get over stuff just show them
what they want all right there's no game
pass announcements besides those games
because it was just like yo games we
don't necessarily have to show you like
we selling you our Wares you know before
it's like yo game passes
they understand at this point though
that everybody knows that everything
they show pretty much is coming to gay
pass they they finally I think got to
that point with that I I would say the
only thing about not showing anything at
the gaming Wars and this is all
hindsight because we didn't know they
were going to do this right um the
biggest thing is a lot of eyes are on
that show it's like one of the biggest
game shows out there and Microsoft
wasn't there so that's when people were
like kind of wondering like what's
really good you know everybody wants the
theory craft like why aren't they there
do they have stuff is there more issues
going on it just it's compounded with
all the stuff that's been happening at
Microsoft over the course of the last
couple of weeks and months so if like
you said that they continue this this we
do this this is the best way forward for
them because this is how they built
Their audience this is how you get to
the point where people want to come and
just see your show and you can say we
don't need to go to anybody else's show
you could be like how Nintendo did it I
actually I actually think
that's
they didn't go to the Video Game Awards
because they just had too much to show
if they had like one thing they probably
could have done it but you know giving
the Video Game Awards any of those
announcements is going to take away from
your own show so yeah I think but they
should have been there in some way maybe
a sea of Thieves they should have been
there hey I'm sorry to interrupt I gotta
go guys I really appreciate you having
me in a minute no doubt I don't think
I think this this okay so my opinion of
them not being at the game awards yeah
this was smart
okay start establishing your own Beach
head okay right and use them you don't
need them but use them when you want to
use them right so if you have a
peripheral announcement or we have a new
limited edition Xbox or you know
whatever use them for something that you
need to sell the public this is really
for your whole Court you this is you
singing to your choir right and let your
choir go out and speak to the masses in
fact so nobody know about this show
unless they hear from Xbox dude oh did
you hear about that game because if they
show this game at the game awards or
they show a game that they've shown
already we're gonna be like we saw it
out we saw that already I get that right
and then you then you take away the
Thunder of this because this game really
hit you know and then it's dropping
right now I really want to get off this
line
I'll try to see if we were searchable on
the app I can find on the app to did
y'all find it people say they're
downloading
before I even came on I said man if you
want me to be on then I can talk about
it
um addict something came up um
and I love that high five Rush was there
because again
by any issue with them in the past is I
hate when they try to kill the
expectation don't expect nothing else
just this this this this this this and
you gotta have once in a while that yo
y'all didn't talk okay we know about
this joint like you need that you need
that wonder that gets the stealth drive
and the fact is like yo right now boom
like I'm like oh this is going to be
like a second half day that I don't know
it was right now it's right now so yeah
that's what's up I couldn't find
anything and try to do it yeah right
here it's in the store
search from the search from the store
online or don't do the app oh don't do
Game Pass go to Microsoft app itself
yeah okay and then hot what is it high
hyphen and then yeah high is hyphen in
the middle between high five that's true
downloading let's go yeah yep yep there
you go there you go
this is guys
happens when stealth drops happen and
this is what happens when you have Game
Pass did that say seventy dollars no it
didn't
oh my God yo yo shout out to Xbox for
giving you that joke I'm inside
I know you feel sad for smoking because
your wallet is for broken I'm done
catch this work man all day cause
somebody called me an Xbox chill and
said I get paid off a shilling for Xbox
[Laughter]
before we roll out the [__] out of here
it feels good chilling for Xbox I'll be
playing high five while you be playing
go cry
[Music]
what's going on my move because the
people find what you got going on
popping uh you could find me at the log
Nets uh Discord uh at wayhick w-a-y
h-i-k Twitter and that Lord's the game
on the website itself yes sir no doubt
and the DPS King Mr gaming Forte where
can people find you bro yeah man get me
Forte Everywhere YouTube Twitter Xbox
Live and Playstation uh DPS will be to
tomorrow night 9 pm solo backslash
Channel make sure you come through check
it out great to be here missed you guys
yes it's been a minute holidays is over
I can finally get back to doing what do
we do yes sir I appreciate it but as
always have a good weekend guys to be
safe out there the weather sucks yeah
it's great not over here in New York is
dope
wait till tomorrow
and of course the young wolf I see you
out there getting it helped his wealth
looking to find people finding what you
got going on sir you can find me on
Twitter at Lord
you can find me on the attic show in 45
minutes in 45 minutes
yeah I was about to cry no I'm just
tired man
walking me to death over here I went
straight I literally walked straight in
after the gym and sat down like I I
didn't like that's why I had to eat like
during the streaming
yeah
potassium and of course the king himself
wig can't they find you sir yeah check
it out right so wifey saw me getting
dressed she was like well what are you
gonna wear you're gonna go with the all
black because I said yo yeah I'm gonna
wear the scarf you know so she was like
you gonna wear the all black I said nah
General we at War
we had war I said the general you know
got the patches for the wall you know my
heart don't pump Kool-Aid
this is for the for the ponies with the
third eye open you know I'm saying this
is the patches that we caught when we
caught them in the war we caught them
flipping this right here this is the
last face you see before we go there
okay I put I put the r r YouTube channel
in the chat let's go
and you honor something you wanted
something right there
and and if I catch you laughing if I
catch you lacking this is it right here
so why we have water what's going on
what's going on with these dudes man
stop playing I got dudes that's that's
not even following me tagging me this is
what you get for tagging me oh a 9 out
of 10 show go to sleep so pretty get on
your tablet
I want to explain real quick so pretty
much what me and King are doing is uh
we're building another YouTube channel
for like 2 TV and movie stuff because we
don't want to like cross promote them
too much on the same channel I feel like
you know keeping this gaming for the
most part besides the podcast and
keeping that TV movie uh you know if you
guys don't want to watch the r r because
you don't have time or you only like
care about like The Last of Us review
and that's all like we're gonna have all
that individual videos on that channel
so the channel I put in the the chat
over there in sub uh you know we already
have the first two episodes of me King
reviewing the Last of Us show so go over
there and I will be doing every episode
when Marvel comes out we'll be doing
that screen will be uh spoiler cast and
that it's gonna be a lot of content over
there I think me and key might get into
reactions too on that channel yeah every
new movie coming out me and attic is
going to see them uh that day as soon as
they come out also instead of time
stamps because a lot of you guys be
coming at us for time stamps yeah I
ain't doing them it's not gonna be a
time stamp it's just gonna be an episode
about that subject so we do probably
three movies uh per show and it's going
to be three different it's going to be
broken down into three different
episodes that you can check so if you
don't care about a sick you can just go
to the last of us
let's get that super chat hold on yeah
Massey wreck wow yo King they'll be
playing for broken oh God oh God with
the two dollar Super Chat that's what I
love oh God hold on hold on Jimmy
Harrison with the five dollar Super Chat
damn good show fellas thank you for this
no doubt really no doubt Jimmy sure
thank you thank you for pulling up hit
that everybody but
um yeah that's all I got everybody check
out my man addict he pulling up attic
show and again everybody for pulling up
on a direct good show and uh we're gonna
talk about a lot of stuff this Sunday in
the realm but that's all I got addict we
out yeah this is
oh new merch dropping yes before Sunday
look at my Twitter for when I put it up
if you want to be a part of packs we're
gonna do something special for everybody
that gets a Pax East shirt we're gonna
try it let's not make sure
we're gonna try we're gonna do something
we're gonna do something very special
for y'all all right so
um uh we're going to uh invade fund
speculation over there I have the
channel going over there after we end
the podcast go there tell them that uh
the Lord sent you man I want that exact
sound I'm gonna go over there and look
too I better see something you can put
that in that yeah real quick what deeper
saying he said Xbox confirmed it will
return to Los Angeles for a showcase
this summer ahead of the first physical
E3 show we'll confirmed that before we
head off because I just seen this
check the Xbox Twitter y'all see if XBox
don't put something up out there and see
what's going on drop
um Math's channel in the chat so people
can see it so they can go off the link
yes someone give me that link
um
I I got the link up
and
yeah I got it right here see like
passion projects like high uh five rush
like that's so unique people are just
gonna gravitate towards
yeah that drink look crazy
I'm out of here I got a game of
um of high five to play and